how do you feel about the quality of
storytelling that you're seeing in the
world today I mean it's a good question
what do i how do I feel about the
quality of storytelling that's a good
question I don't know I'm not really
attracted to a lot of new stuff I think
because I've seen it before and that's
just my personal thing at this point I
think it's just an age thing and also
it's a it's a result of being a film
nerd because when you consume as much
cinema as I have in my lifetime you've
you have seen in most cases the best
iterations of a particular story or
genre already so when I see something
new that just manages to be good
execution or a well executed version of
a story that I've already seen it's not
enough for me anymore so I don't you
know I find myself going back to the
films that have that really changed my
life that really did it best because I
want to be nourished in that way it's
not enough for me to see something
that's just a really good yarn that was
well directed and well produced even
though that's a monumental feat any
filmmaker will tell you you know that
making a good movie is a miracle but for
me personally I I tend to look to the
Past for the inspiration because I feel
like in most cases it it was done best
and and and that doesn't mean that I'm
I'm resistant to somebody showing me
something that's truly brilliant because
I would welcome that if somebody showed
me something that was just
earth-shatteringly brilliant that I
better than anything else then I would
be like Jesus Christ thank you you know
I want to see that stuff and I'm sure
it's out there I'm sure it's out there I
just haven't seen anything lately I know
like The Handmaid's Tale it was a movie
with righteth McGovern right in the 80s
I think or nine early 90s uh yeah that
what do you mean the original hand mates
- yeah yeah and so now now it's like got
a whole new life to it right exactly
yeah yeah and it's now they're spoofing
it on Saturday Night Live right you know
right but but back then I I don't
remember if I
really hurt a lot no no it's funny I
actually I think it was in the 80s I was
actually an intern at the production
company where they were making that
movie
remember xeroxing and up the
Xeroxes I remember I think it was a dad
who was the director of that of the
original Handmaid's Tale I can't believe
I'm blanking on this german director but
anyway there was it was in New York City
I was like you know a PA and the office
and they were having this special lunch
meeting or something and I was charged
with getting the new draft together and
I was like you know just printing this
thing out and whether it was jammed in
the print my ran over to 21 or ever they
were having dinner and I remember giving
it to the producer and it was like all
the pages were out of order and
everything he's looking at me
judgmentally I'm like I'm never gonna
work in this business yeah well a good
story I mean a good story that is that
that a filmmaker or writer finds a way
in that that changes it or makes it more
contemporary or more resonant or or
personal whatever it is I mean I think
that's that's totally valid too but I
just haven't seen much recently that's
like blown me away right I mean it's
kind of like you know a band that does
you know you know when the levee breaks
or something right like okay it sounded
so great when Robert Plant saying it but
now you're doing it it sounds good but
it just doesn't have the same value but
again is it a generational thing because
I know you and I were just talking on
writer about video discs and just seeing
older like even 90s Sherm's that it just
had a different feel to it yeah well I
think that's true I mean I talked to my
students about this all the time and I
think it's a it's a it's an amazing age
and it's a horrible age it's amazing in
the sense that anything you want to see
from the history of the world is
available like you know like that like
gone are the days of hunting for a
revival house that's going to be showing
the third man or Seven Samurai or what
have you or anything for that matter or
the last detail or whatever it is it's
not like you have to like hunt for a
video store now that they exist anymore
that's going to carry a special John Woo
Hong Kong action thing when they can't
find like everything is available at any
given moment
that said there is so much material
there's so much available that I I
wouldn't know where to begin and I think
that that's a problem because unless
there's somebody a teacher or film geek
parent or somebody saying spend your
time watching this this this and this
before you watch this other stuff
because that's going to educate you
that's going to make you a better
filmmaker then you're bound to lose
those great things and I'm not even
talking about like the obvious classics
I'm just talking about even minor films
that are still better than a lot of junk
that you see today you're never gonna
see them then they're never gonna see
them because there's just too much to
look at and so I'm sort of losing the
threat of the question but I think Mike
my feeling is is that there's just
almost too much to see now and it'd be
better if you I don't know if someone
helped me it's almost like you you need
to graduate you have to like you there's
a prerequisite that you have to watch
all this stuff if you're gonna be a
filmmaker and then you can watch as much
junk as you want that's out now you know
something like that
alright well a lot of stuff seems over
processed you know like two to two
overproduced yahweh's and maybe just as
a culture we've become used to that so
if it's not packaged that way yeah we
don't want it I think you're right I
think we were talking about this earlier
I think that if social media is over
produced in other words if somebody's
personal Instagram page with all its
requisite filters and yeah you know with
this glamour and and and the tools of
production in the hands of anybody and
it raises this level this this this
standard of what is acceptable to a
professional level in a certain way but
it also creates a certain artifice as
you know one of my favorite quotes that
John Cassavetes said about Hollywood
films in general is that they're an
advertisement for life that's what he
said because Hollywood movies
in most cases are an advertisement for
life and he was saying whereas my films
which are clearly comparatively very
rough and perhaps even mistakenly looked
upon as almost
amateurish compared to that polish and
mistakenly because that was by design by
him because he he was a professional but
he made his films look a certain way
because he was trying to get at
something that was the opposite that he
was trying to get at the messiness the
reality of life whereas Hollywood almost
by definition tries to minimize that in
favor of this gloss or polish or
illusion you know and so yeah I think
that becomes this the diet that you're
consuming then if you see something
that's grittier or Messier or and I'm
not even talking about the look I'm
talking about the content where the
content is not just this clearly safe
define thing people may have a
resistance to that they may go whoa this
is not I don't want this this is too
much this is not what I'm you know this
is not the food I've chosen to eat but
what does it do to your tastes you know
it limits your tastes to only want this
candy and not something that's more
substituted for what's the right word
substantial in that way you know it's
nourishing I was just watching part of
the Stepford Wives which one oh of the
original yeah
and just how you know they're like the
long driving sequence in their game with
all the credits and the classic like
yeah that was it 70s yeah I think you
okay track you know at the time that we
would hear all the time and now it
sounds so wonderful but at the time
every show and movie had it that's right
but you know just how it was so quiet of
in terms of there's there's just moments
where it's it's not like something's
happening every second right right right
reading yeah and I think that's that's
actually you know I've always said this
and anybody will tell you this that the
strength of a spike in a story or our
movie where something goes crazy where
there's a lot of kinetic activity or
surprise or whatever is directly related
to the quiet that precedes it in other
words something is super loud or big
relative to what preceded it so that's
why in a horror movie and then you know
they learn this going all the way back
to the 30s but if you if you have a very
quiet almost nothing happen
and then a huge scare that scare becomes
magnified whereas if you have to
maintain what is now you know the
classic Hollywood mantra of just a
thrill every second
then each then that thrill every second
becomes a plateau you just become
accustomed to it it's not going to it's
not going to hit you the same way if you
allowed for that quiet to proceed it but
that assumes that the audience or
probably assumes it seems that the
producers are willing to allow that
quiet to happen and not be go oh
people are going to be bored we got to
do something exciting and you can be
have this length of quiet and that the
audiences are willing to invest in that
and be okay with that and say this is
not boring this is interesting and then
be the beneficiary of the result of that
if something huge follows it because
it'll be huger you know because of it
you